President Trump today makes his first
visit since taking office to California
where many state and local leaders
oppose his immigration policies Governor
Jerry Brown wrote a letter to the
president saying quote California
thrives because we welcome immigrants he
adds we are focusing on bridges not
walls major Garrett is at the White
House major good morning good morning
the Trump Justice Department is suing
the state of California the underlying
issue sanctuary cities and what the
federal government alleges as
California's refusal to participate in
the enforcement of federal immigration
policy now back in January the Mayor of
the City of Oakland Libby Schaaf told
reporters she was willing to go to jail
to protect her city's sanctuary status
president Trump is expected while in
California today to discuss this entire
issue of sanctuary cities and the clash
with the federal government in advance
of that trip and those comments last
night administration officials sought to
dispel what they described as myths
about sanctuary cities and the
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
Agency which has recently stepped up
raids in several cities across
California acting director of ice Thomas
Holman told reporters quote we don't
arrest innocent people either they are
here in violation of federal law or they
had their due process unquote and are
therefore ignoring lawful removal orders
even so the ice spokesman in the city of
San Francisco recently resigned in
protest over the administrations of use
of what that former spokesman called
inaccurate false information put out in
response to raids in the City of Oakland
now President Trump will also visit San
Diego and there he will inspect eight
different prototypes for the planned
wall on the us-mexico border Congress
has not provided the 15 to 20 billion
dollars estimated to require to build
that wall Nora that money is tied to
negotiations currently stalled over
other immigration reform issues all
right major thank you so much